foreign
hi I'm sandy guy product manager for
lodb and I'm abhinav khushraj product
manager for bigquery
today we're going to be talking about
how databases can help you more easily
add ml to your applications
we see a lot of app developers looking
to build better experiences using
machine learning whether that's a mobile
app developer looking to use AIML to
optimize a customer journey to a
retailer looking to offer the right
product to the right customer or
financial services user looking to
detect fraud within a transaction
there are so many opportunities to build
more personal more intelligent
experiences in your applications but you
know Sandy while people see a lot of
Promise in what Ai and ml can do for
their business they are struggling to
operationalize AI initiatives
you know what happens typically
typically Enterprise will spend a lot of
time and energy to build data pipelines
to bring data into a warehouse they'll
build governance models around it and so
on however when they want to do an ml
project they have to take that data out
again not only do they have to build and
maintain new pipelines to export the
data it often results in loss of
governance and can lead to security
issues and finally there's the headache
of figuring out and maintaining
infrastructure both for training and
inference either the underserved
creating a bad experience or over serve
resulting in huge costs
so the traditional approach results in
skill gaps significant cost and
complexity and can lead to security
issues and that means fewer customers
actually integrate machine learning into
their apps I think we can both agree
that there's a better way absolutely
let's show them
chances are you are already using a
database to back your application and a
data warehouse for Analytics
today abhinav and I are going to talk
you through a demo on how you can use
your existing stack to build models and
integrate them with your apps without
having to move data around you can even
use your existing SQL skills to both
train models and deploy them in your
applications
there are a few products that make this
super easy today we're going to talk
about alloy DB and bigquery
alloy DB is a fully postgres compatible
database Engine with Superior
performance availability and scale it's
great for demanding workloads it's four
times faster than standard postgres for
transactional workloads
but it also allows you to unify
analytical workloads and generate more
real-time insights on your data
but one of my favorite things about
alloy DB is its native integration with
vertex AI with alloy TB you can call a
model in vertex AI directly from the
database enabling high throughput low
latency augmented transactions
one of the examples we're going to talk
about today is a fraud detection use
case
loadb can call a fraud detection model
within a transaction
so if John Doe tries to make a purchase
for twenty dollars we can call vertex AI
using this ml predict function and
determine if it's fraudulent as we save
it down
this feature is actually also available
in Cloud spanner which is gcp's
relational database offering with
unlimited scale strong consistency and
up to five nines of availability
bigquery is an industry-leading cloud
data warehouse processing 110 terabytes
of data every single second it has a
serverless design users don't have to
worry about managing scale whether you
have just a few hundred rows or billions
of rows bigquery automatically scales up
or down to manage it and it is unique in
the industry to have built-in capability
for doing ml with bigquery ML by being
right inside the database it removes the
need to manage data and bigquery manages
all the training and serving
infrastructure Enterprise is large and
small have trained millions of models
using bigquery ml for a variety of use
cases ranging from forecasting customer
segmentation or anomaly detection
in fact its usage grew by over 200
percent in 2022
bigquery ml brings bigquery and vertex
together to create a simplified data to
AI Journey it integrates with vertex in
many different ways users can train
models for bigquery leveraging vertexes
training infrastructure or users can
write a few lines of SQL code to run
inference against Google's
state-of-the-art pre-trained models for
images natural language or translation
and finally for Enterprise users that
provide the seamless mlops experience
for managing models building a feature
Store and More
what's so cool about these products is
that they make it easy to integrate ml
into your existing apps today we're
going to walk through a fraud detection
use case
first let's start with the existing
application you are already using alloy
DB as your database and storing your
retail transactions there
you might also have a database pipeline
using data stream that is replicating
data to bigquery for offline analytics
and maybe even a looker dashboard for
reporting
now we'd like to start incorporating ml
to predict whether our retail
transactions are fraudulent we can use
vertex Ai gcp's Ai and ml platform to
build deploy and scale machine learning
models faster with fully managed ml
tools for any use case
this integrates nicely with both
bigquery and alloy DB
so first we need to train our model for
data scientists who want full control
vertex AI offers custom Training but for
the many users who don't have data
science expertise or who want to speed
up time to Market
bigquery ml can help you train a model
super quickly and all you need is SQL
users write a simple SQL query with a
create model statement specifying the
model type and the training data set
that is inside bigquery and then in
addition to that during model creation
users specify an option to register the
model with vertex ai's model registry
now this makes it super easy for
Enterprises to have a single place to
manage all their models and once the
model is registered users can go to
vertex AI to create a prediction
endpoint
and deploy the model for online serving
using vertex AI prediction while
specifying the serving infrastructure
that they like it's that easy Sandy so
now we've trained our model and
registered an endpoint let's talk about
inference how do we actually integrate
those predictions into our apps
again alloy DB makes that easy because
you can call your vertex AI endpoint
from the database itself I'm turning it
over to Gabe Weiss to show you how this
works
[Music]
we're going to walk through how you can
invoke predictions on vertex AI
endpoints from alloy DB using SQL
this is functionality lodb provides so
that users don't have to manually build
a custom integration for machine
learning
here's our project where an alloy DB
cluster has been created and we will be
using the primary instance in this
cluster to invoke predictions
first we need to Grant this alloy DB
cluster permissions to access vertex AI
to Grant those permissions we need the
project number to find it navigate to
the project dashboard and project number
should be listed under project info
we're using a separate project for our
vertex AI endpoints as you can see we
have a fraud detection endpoint deployed
here already
instructions to train and deploy this
model will be linked in the description
below
to Grant permissions go to the IAM page
of the same project and click on ADD
paste the principle in the format
mentioned in the documentation and
change the project number to the value
we got from our alloy DB project
choose the vertex AI user role so that
allodb clusters in that project can
invoke predictions on vertex Ai and
finally click save
as we can see the principal has been
granted the necessary permissions and
now alloyodb instances should be able to
access vertex AI endpoints note in some
scenarios users might have to check the
include Google provided role grants box
to view the principle we just added in
this list
now to finally invoke predictions on the
endpoints we need some details navigate
back to the vertex AI endpoints page in
this case we want to invoke predictions
on the fraud detection endpoint click on
the sample request link take note of the
endpoint ID and project ID also note the
region in which this endpoint is
deployed in this case it's us Central 1.
now the final step is to invoke
predictions on this endpoint using SQL
we will connect to the ledb's primary
instance from a client VM in the alloy
DB project
we are using the PG CLI client which is
a wrapper over psql to connect to the
fraud database
let's create a table fraud detection
data which will contain transactions
over which prediction will be invoked to
determine whether a particular
transaction is fraudulent or not
for demonstration purposes we'll load
data from a CSV file into this table
let's look at some rows in this table
some of our data has been transformed to
protect user identities and sensitive
features that's why we see the data in
this form and columns named as V1 V2 Etc
and some columns have been preserved as
is like time and amount
to invoke predictions we'll be using a
function named ml predict row this
function is provided by the Google
vertex AI extension for Alloy DB to use
it we need to install the extension
first using the create extension command
now that the extension is installed
let's start with a query which runs
predictions on some rows of our fraud
detection data table
for each row ml predict row will be
called with relevant arguments the first
argument of the ml predict row function
is the endpoint and we plugged in
Project ID region and endpoint ID into
this format which we got earlier from
the sample request
the second argument is a Json object
with an instances key containing the
actual data that we want to get the
prediction scores for
we want to get individual prediction
scores for each row which is why row to
Json here is converting a row in the
table to Json
the response Json object returned by
vertex will contain prediction scores in
the predictions key so here you see
we're extracting data from the
predictions key using this operator
finally we're limiting the number of
rows to 500 just for demonstration
purposes now let's execute our query
the response will take a little time so
we're speeding up a bit here to get to
the good stuff
this is the response returned by the
query we have a Time column that is
directly projected from the table and
fraud score column which contains the
prediction results
class 0 here means the transaction is
non-fraudulent and class 1 means that
the transaction is fraudulent
so for the first row the prediction
score corresponding to class 0 is 0.99
which is significantly higher than the
score corresponding to class 1 meaning
the model is predicted that this
transaction is non-flaudulent however
looking at our second row the score
corresponding to class 0 is only 0.1
which is significantly lower than the
score corresponding to class 1 meaning
the model predicted that this
transaction is fraudulent
this query took around 14 and a half
seconds to execute because we're sending
only one row to each request for vertex
AI as in 500 requests just got sent to
vertex AI to get predictions for the 500
rows
to improve throughput we can send
multiple rows in a single request to
vertex AI our next query will do exactly
that
we're going to use Group by Clause to
batch multiple rows together just to
demonstrate we're going to group on a
random integer ranging from 0 to 4
meaning there can be at most five groups
or batches and since we're invoking
predictions on 500 rows the expected
batch size would be about a hundred
now the data under the instances key
will be a list of Json objects instead
of a single Json object like the
previous query we generate this list
using the Json mag function
finally we also then need to unpack the
aggregated rows into individual rows
unnest and Json array elements functions
are responsible for doing that work now
let's run the query
we roughly see around a 21 times
Improvement even though both the queries
are invoking predictions on the same
sets of rows so just by batching we can
get significant performance improvements
the amount of performance Improvement
will obviously vary from case to Case
and depends on factors like Network
latency batch size number of parallel
workers used by the queries Etc
thanks for watching
[Music]
wow that was pretty cool and super easy
Sandy thanks so now we've trained our
model and deployed it into our
application we didn't need to move data
around or host or manage any additional
resources
we also didn't need any specific data
science skills we were able to run and
train our predictions using just SQL
thanks so much for tuning in to learn
more about using alloy DB and bigquery
to integrate machine learning into your
applications check out the description
below
[Music]
foreign